Elon Musk lost more than 200 billion  dollars in wealth in 2022 no one has  ever lost as much money as has Elon Musk  but he's still going to be fine the more  interesting story is a lot of this was  self-inflicted much of that loss and net  worth came because of Tesla and much of  the Tesla decline is yes a changing  Market environment around electric  vehicles but also the perception that  seems to at least to some degree  accurate that Elon Musk is increasingly  distracted from Tesla by shiny new  objects like Twitter so to some degree  this is Elon musk's own doing what the  future of Twitter or Tesla now are  remains a real question what do you  think let me know in the comments